as businesses big and small across
Canada begin to reopen there's one
sector that has stalled travel
especially the airline industry
Air Canada has laid off 20,000 people
more than half of its workforce and this
week WestJet announced it is laying off
more than 3,300 workers domestic flights
are still happening though much reduced
its international air travel that's
really tanked passenger arrivals at
Canadian airports were down 95 percent
last week compared to 2019 that's
according to the Canada Border Services
Agency if you do decide to fly the rules
around air travel are changing both for
airlines and for passengers crystal dome
ancing shows us how the Colosseum is an
iconic symbol of the past its future
however rests in these sanitized hands
of its visitors so many of the world's
top attractions are reopening but to
fall in love with these sites something
else has to happen first
[Music]
people have to start flying again hi my
name is Miranda de Pernod and I was last
on a flight April 28th flying from
Montreal to Vancouver April was the
worst month on record for the aviation
sector the industry bottomed out as the
deadly pandemic swept across Europe and
over to North America the company that
directs air traffic above the UK some of
the busiest airspace in the world
created this flight comparison showing
just how different the sky appeared in
April 2019 compared to April this year I
felt pretty alright with things I think
perhaps has to do with my age but I know
my mom was very nervous about flying and
everyone yeah everyone on the fly it was
like fully some people were in full like
painter's suits with their hair tucked
away and goggles and masks and gloves
and everything most I mean everyone had
a mask on most people had gloves on and
then the the energy of the flight I
could feel the air so just intense like
you could hear a pin drop
what a surreal experience
yeah even just I mean the body language
of the people around you you know I
think we've kind of gotten into this
place with flight to China claim space
and I can feel instead of you know
people's shoulders being back and kind
of spreading out and wanting to take
that space it was almost the exact
opposite where it was all these layers
and scarves and just people wanted as
much you know to be kept to themselves
as possible keeping ourselves locked
away at home was exactly what we were
all directed to do now the message is
changing we are now at a period of time
that we need to learn how to coexist
with the virus the International Air
Transport Association says resuming air
travel is key to restarting economies
however the agency's own polling shows
flyers in 11 countries including Canada
or hesitant three sets of poles by IATA
shows overall concern about the virus
remains high for Canadians going from
63% in February to 80% this month when
it comes to the question of returning to
travel the majority of those polled 55%
say they'll wait at least six months
before traveling hello my name is Ronnie
Solomon and I flew from London UK to
Toronto Canada on June 19 I had a lot of
anxiety around that because I was like
am I making the right choice
traveling it wasn't busy it wasn't
followed by any means and I think that
went a long way in alleviating some of
the stress that I had because the middle
seats were all blocked up and while I
was placed in a pod of three the middle
seat was empty and then there was a
gentleman sitting on the aisle side
public health is a new layer to air
travel safety the industry is
replicating what's being done in other
sectors to try and protect people from
kovat 19 masks are universal temperature
checks are widely used some countries
are opting to test travellers and
cleaning efforts have been enhanced in
airports and on planes non-essential
foreign travel is still not recommended
for Canadians but come next month the
plan is for most of Europe to re open to
international visitors a big part of the
reason comes down to money
Greece is ready to welcome tourists this
summer by putting their safety and their
health as a number-one priority
in some countries visitors have to
quarantine but there is a huge amount of
pressure from industry on governments to
scrap those restrictions they're seen as
yet another barrier to restarting air
travel from this vantage point at London
City Airport we should be watching lots
of planes coming and going but there
just isn't the demand the airlines this
year expect to post a loss of 84 million
dollars
that will have a ripple effect on
millions of jobs attached to the sector
the passenger is going to have more
responsibilities he's going to have to
be fit for travel which in the different
in the path wasn't necessarily indicate
but that's what's going to help us
reduce the risk but many people don't
know they're sick travel has led to new
infections New Zealand was virus-free
four weeks until two seemingly healthy
women visited from the UK and ended up
testing positive Beijing saw flights
canceled recently and new clusters of
kovat 19 led to localised lockdowns this
is where risk because it's such an
interesting concept to mull over my
personal opinion is if you don't need to
travel then don't travel until there's
some kind of you know vaccine or people
are feeling comfortable with where the
numbers are at I do think the way that
we gather around one another be it in a
plane or on the bus or on the subway
there's definitely gonna be a new
awareness and consciousness that's who
is around you and what sounds sneezes
fluids are maybe coming from your area
the industry is working to rebuild
consumer confidence the recovery from
covet 19 is expected to take years
airlines are banking on their not being
a second wave and on our desire to get
back out and see the world
[Music]